Speaker 1: Let's let's talk to
some other people. I mean, listen,
but why not? Right. We're doing it. Let's
go to Emmanuel from New York. Emmanuel,
welcome. Welcome back. I know
I've spoken to you right now.
Speaker 3: You have? All right.
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
Speaker 4: I have a question for you like. But
do you or do you think like, um, do you think
do you think political violence will be enough?
They kind of like kind of like necessary because
like, if you look at history, people are used
to go by like, do you know about the country,
Rhodesia? You know, you heard about.
Speaker 1: It, right? I know. I'm
familiar with Rhodesia.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Basically,
like they were treated the majority black by is
like crap. Yeah. Until they fought back and you
know, they won the war because Zimbabwe it's an
out now thing. So like do you think that we can
apply that to like what's happening the Supreme
Court was voting the issue with the voting issue,
abortion and policing in America.
Speaker 1: You know, maybe this is me being
naively optimistic, but I also, from a practical
standpoint, don't think that violence is going to
be the solution here because violence is not going
to. Let me see how I can put this. The United
States right now, it's almost like a logistical
problem, violence to achieve goals in the United
States. The U.S. is mostly blue, you know,
left leaning cities within kind of like purple
metro areas inside of right leaning rural
areas across a vast expanse of land. And I
just don't know from a practical standpoint
how even just saying, like, if we're okay
morally with using violence to achieve change,
I don't know how in a country like the U.S.,
that's how you do it. It just seems like
chaos and and death and injury and insanity
without actually really achieving political
change to say we're we're just going to use
violence. I'm also morally opposed to
it, but that's a different question.
Speaker 4: Like in Zimbabwe, they did
achieve the goals because, you know,
you know what happened to it.
Speaker 1: I'm not that
familiar with Zimbabwean history.
Speaker 4: Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. So like
one more question. Do you think the the happiness
of people with abortion will change the effect of
the Latino vote? Because, like my parents would
vote for Democrat, but like if you look at them,
they're very conservative actually. Like because
I although that element Telemundo is show and you
know that Spanish channel. Yeah and basically
one woman said she was she said I'm like, I'm
Democrat, I don't like abortion. So like, what did
I like in my mind? Like, wait till the candidate
actually changed the Latino vote. The Latino.
Speaker 3: Vote.
Speaker 1: So it is true. So the Latino vote
in the U.S. is interesting. The Latino vote is
generally left wing other than Cubans in some
Venezuelans, but the Latino vote is also very
Catholic. And so there is more anti-abortion
sentiment among the Latino vote than some
might believe. I think if there is any impact
from the Roe v Wade decision on 2022, I think
it helps Democrats. I don't know how to slice and
dice it within the Latino vote, but I think the
polling is already telling us that if anybody's
going to benefit from the Roe v Wade decision,
it's going to be Democrats in the fall. We'll see.
Speaker 4: Still. But do you think
do you think there have a little effect or no?
Speaker 1: I think that on in general or on the
Latino vote in general, yes, I think that
the Roe v Wade decision will have an effect
and it will help Democrats in the fall.
Speaker 4: I thank you for the question
and good luck with the baby.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you
very much. Appreciate the call. That does
it for today, folks. I know. I didn't get
to everyone. I never do. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. But we got to a bunch of people
and we will speak to more people next week.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.